[Music]
jay's with us in gilbert arizona hi shea
welcome to the ramsey show
hi guys thank you for having me and
taking my call sure um i so long story
short i'm 22 years old married on baby
step number two um with my debt of
our trust that's 23 000 and we bought a
home last july
so my question is is
to set us up kind of for
future and to skip baby steps should we
sell our house so we could move on to
baby step five or six
and also my motive for this is to
buy me a car i don't have a car to buy
me a car in cash and to feel comfortable
having kids we want to have kids
um fairly soon so um and i never want to
go back into debt ever so
that's my question what's your household
income
uh we make 65 around 65 000 after taxes
okay
wow
i usually tell folks not to sell a house
unless they just hate their house
because it's so expensive emotionally
and financially to move
i usually tell you to plow your way
through the other stuff now how much
debt have you got at not counting the
house 23
23 000 yeah and you make 66. and you're
not working or he is or both of you
working or what
we yeah we're both working um
i'm sorry what was that both of you
working 40 hours
yeah what do y'all
do he's an hvac just started in hvac so
he's kind of um going up the ranks and
i'm in real estate i i'm a repair
coordinator
okay and what do you make
um i make fifty thousand
and he's making fourteen
uh
sixty-five
yeah so i
he's making around paychecks like 1300
every paycheck
how many paychecks does he get
once every two weeks
that's 30 000.
40 000. um
35 37 000. so
okay so you really are making 90 000
between the two of you you have 23 000
worth of debt no unless you hate your
house i would roll up your sleeves and
keep your house and get on a really
tight beans and rice rice and beans
budget scorched earth quit going out to
eat girl
get yourself on a budget and both of you
take all the ot you can get let's get
this stupid student loan paid off and
then save up to an emergency fund and
talk about buying you a car and starting
babies